des voix dans le vent chronique d'un
débat public de Cyril Gallais un film
qui interroge la consultation citoyenne
mais aussi et c'est l'angle que nous
avons choisi aujourd'hui l'éolien
emmerent pourquoi l'éolien est-il
toujours si contesté pourquoi
suscite-t-il même des réactions
épidermiques parlons-en avec nos invités
ici présentenant dans tech bienvenue
vous êtes sénateur écologiste de la
Loire-Atlantique la Loire-Atlantique qui
est le seul département de France à être
doté d'un parc éolien offshore
entièrement service en activité depuis
novembre 2022 donc on a un petit peu de
recul et on en parlera et je précise que
vous êtes aussi vice-président de la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
au Sénat Alain Cadec bienvenue à vous
également vous êtes sénateur des
Côtes-d'Armor apparentés au groupe LR
les Côtes-d'Armor département concernées
par le projet de parc éolien en mer en
baie de Saint-Brieuc dont l'appel
d'offre a été lancée en 2011 si je ne me
trompe pas et dont la mise en service
complète et prévue à l'horizon 2025 je
précise enfin que vous êtes
vice-président de la commission des
affaires européennes et membre de la
commission des affaires économiques
Cédric Philibert également avec nous
bienvenue à vous vous êtes chercheur
associé à l'IFRI institut français des
relations internationales professeur à
Sciences Po analyste pendant 20 ans à
l'Agence nationale de l'énergie
internationale de l'énergie c'est encore
mieux et vous êtes l'auteur de ce livre
que l'on vous présente on présente à
l'instant et auliennes pourquoi tant de
haine aux éditions les petits matins
Jean-Louis buttré bienvenue à vous
également vous êtes fondateur et
président de la Fédération environnement
durable vous êtes l'auteur de plusieurs
tribunes contre l'éolien dans le Figaro
notamment et vous êtes l'auteur d'un
livre sur le sujet et au lien une
catastrophe silencieuse coût nuisance
efficacité les chiffres qui font peur
aux éditions l'artilleur ça nous donne
déjà une idée assez précise de vos
points de vue respectifs je voudrais
qu'on soit pour commencer très concret
très pragmatique pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent et
aux liens en mer avantage inconvénients
Dantec chez vous le parc est déjà en
service est-ce que vous n'y voyez que
des avantages et les quels
d'abord c'est un parc qui a créé un
consensus qui est donc très très
différent y compris au moment du débat
public puisque le documentaire est quand
même documentaire sur le débat c'est pas
un documentaire qui structure le débat
sur l'éolien pour ou contre nous il y a
eu un débat il y a eu un consensus il y
a eu un consensus avec notamment les
pêcheurs qui ont trouvé qui ont trouvé
effectivement leur intérêt dans ce parc
mais aussi ça c'est bien à préciser dans
le documentaire parce que
l'environnement culturel n'est pas le
même Saint-Nazaire c'est un lieu
industriel avec un port de pêche et à
partir de là il y a une culture
industrielle et comme on crée beaucoup
beaucoup d'emplois sur le territoire
nazairien il y a l'éolien
une partie et puis il y a les chantiers
qui font une partie on a trouvé des
équilibres y compris avec des
investissements assez lourds sur le port
de La Turballe grand port
de pêche
l'acceptation et le soutient aussi des
associations de protection de
l'environnement quand le président
Macron est venu tout le monde était sur
le bateau les astres protection de
l'environnement les pêcheurs les
industriels et je crois que c'est autour
de quoi autour de quels avantages
d'abord un consensus sur l'intérêt
économique pour le territoire à très
clairement même s'il y a effectivement
une petite fraction
de la population et de la classe
politique qui était contre c'est-à-dire
les résidences secondaires de la Baule
pour faire un peu simple parce qu'il y a
effectivement des pylônes visibles moi
je ne dis pas du tout qui ne sont pas
avancé très très secondaire par rapport
1 à l'intérêt économique pour le
territoire et deux et ça finalement le
documentaire a beau être assez récent il
est déjà assez daté je crois que on sait
aujourd'hui ça Agnès panière une haché
insiste là-dessus que sans un
développement massif et très rapide de
l'éolien
de participer à l'équilibre énergétique
et économique de la France dans un
territoire qui pourtant est un
spécialiste de l'opposition faire quand
on ne veut pas centrale nucléaire ou
quand on veut pas d'aéroport ça ne se
fait pas mais sur l'éolien il y avait un
consensus d'homme propose qu'on le fasse
si on reste sur cette question et pardon
si elle est un peu simpliste cette
question mais enfin avantage
inconvénient c'est quand même important
pour les gens qui nous regardent elle
est pas simpliste du tout elle est pas
simpliste du tout mais justement pour
faire écho à ce que disait au nom d'un
texte tout de suite dans le département
des Côtes-d'Armor et Saint-Brieuc ça a
été totalement l'inverse c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a eu un rejet global d'abord de
la part de tes pêcheurs aussi de la part
d'un certain nombre de situations tout
simplement parce que c'est un gisement
de coquilles Saint-Jacques extrêmement
important je dirais même avec une
gestion exemplaire reconnue dans le
monde entier qui si on continue comme ça
nous permettra d'avoir de la coquille
Saint-Jacques pour l'éternité
et le parc d'éolien en mer des 62
éoliennes de 24 mètres hauteur vous
imaginez la tour Montparnasse c'est 207
mètres
va s'installer en plein milieu du du du
bassin coquille Saint-Jacques donc ça
pose un problème puisque on pourra plus
les pêcher à cet endroit là donc les
pêcheurs évidemment ont été vend debout
de le lire bien sûr contre contre
l'éolien maintenant en ce qui me
concerne
le mix énergétique il est indispensable
évidemment il faut mettre de l'éolien il
faut mettre un peu de tout mais moi mon
principe mon idée c'est de dire pas
n'importe où pas n'importe comment et
pas n'importe quel prix ce parc éolien
va revenir très cher et va produire un
kilowatt très cher sans doute l'un des
plus chers du monde 155 euros donc
évidemment oui
vous voyez plus d'inconvénients
économique en l'occurrence moi je vois
pas l'intérêt économique
Bretagne a vu l'intérêt économique sur
la région
économique bretons j'ai projeté
dans la région on n'est pas d'accord sur
ce point sur ce sujet si vous le voulez
bien de personnes sont encore exprimées
Jean-Louis butret on a compris quand je
vous ai présenté que vous étiez plutôt
contre voire très contre expliquez-nous
pourquoi pour que les téléspectateurs
comprennent d'abord je représente 1600
associations de toutes les régions de
France et ce sont des gens qui luttent
contre l'éolien terrestre et l'éolien
maritime offshore alors vous savez on
est des citoyens sans moyens et on peut
quand même se poser en France la
question pourquoi il y a autant de gens
en effet qui protestent alors la
deuxième chose c'est que quand j'entends
dire que c'est merveilleux au point de
vue économique et que c'est merveilleux
au point de vue écologique je bonis j'ai
participé aux Grenelle de
l'environnement avec Giscard d'Estaing
j'étais son conseiller à l'époque et
franchement quand je vois le résultat
aujourd'hui de l'électricité en France
et que j'entends il faut faire de
l'éolien en mer il faut faire un mix et
que énergétique moi ce que je constate
c'est qu'en
2000 on avait une électricité fiable pas
cher et qu'on exportait aujourd'hui je
constate en 2023 que depuis 2011 ça va
être merveilleux l'éolien et vous allez
dire que bien sûr ça va s'améliorer etc
et je constate qu'aujourd'hui on a
failli des jonquer les vers dernier on
importait désespérément que le prix de
l'électricité monte
il suffit de regarder votre facture
aujourd'hui plus on met d'éoliennes
entre autres plus on voit la facture
montée je suis désolé mais franchement
si c'est ça l'objectif de la France
c'est-à-dire la plombée économiquement
par quelque chose en plus qui sert à
rien pourquoi parce que les Allemands
ont arrêté le nucléaire alors en 2000 on
disait l'éolien va remplacer le
nucléaire maintenant on dit on c'est un
bon mix énergétique n'empêche que quand
on a des centrales nucléaires on n'a pas
besoin de faire d'éoliennes ni sur
l'éolien offshore est un une bonne
manière de produire de l'électricité
Cédric Philibert alors il faut parler de
l'éolien d'abord en général
c'est vrai qu'en France on a eu une
électricité décarbonée depuis de
nombreuses années grâce au nucléaire nos
centrales nucléaires ont un âge moyen de
37 ans on ne sait pas combien de temps
on va pouvoir les prolonger et si on a
beaucoup manqué d'électricité l'été
dernier c'est d'abord parce que 22
centrales ont dû être arrêtés pour des
réparations c'est ça ça a été ça le
problème fondamental qui est
spécialement mal tombé avec la guerre en
Ukraine et l'augmentation du prix du gaz
dans toute la région
à deux aujourd'hui
l'éolien offshore même ancien c'est à
dire que en fait le Saint-Brieuc a été
conçu il y a presque 15 ans et la
lenteur de nos procédures construit en
ce moment oui ça a été conçu la lenteur
de nos procédures malheureusement fait
que quand on finit un parc on est déjà
très en retard sur ce qui se construit
ailleurs en terme de technologie et de
puissance etc donc on n'est pas dans les
plus performants mais à 150 euros le
mégawattheure c'est une opportunité
parce que nos industriels aujourd'hui
payent le kilowatt-heure à 249 euros en
2023 un contexte géopolitique mais il
paye l'électricité à 249 euros le
mégawattheure et donc y compris de
l'éolien à 200 à 255 si ça devait
continuer ça reste ça reste une
opportunité économique c'est moins cher
que celle qu'on achète en Europe qui est
fabriqué à partir du gaz
ce sont des pêcheurs très en colère qui
dénoncent la perte de leur zone de pêche
la destruction de leurs ressources la
destruction des fonds marins et les
champs électromagnétiques magnétiques
qui détruiraient les coquilles et les
crustacés mais plus que de la colère on
entend aussi une vraie détresse et je
voudrais qu'on réécoute ce pêcheur qu'on
entend et qui est très ému dans le film
de bateau à payer et que tu sais pas ce
que tu vas donner à bouffer à ta fille à
la fin de la semaine quoi ça me
indirectement ça me ça me touche encore
tu vois
on met tout en oeuvre pour faire
disparaître les pêcheurs
et parce que maintenant je crois qu'on
gêne on veut mettre des éoliennes
partout et tous ceux qui travaillent
comme on dire dans la bande où ils
veulent mettre les éoliennes c'est tous
les petits pêcheurs comme moi
qu'est-ce qu'on peut répondre à cet
homme moi je l'avais noté
ça me semble un passage important
puisque effectivement ça n'est pas une
opposition à l'éolien c'est l'éolien
sert finalement de points d'ancrage face
à un monde qui échappe notamment la
pêche artisanale moi je suis finistérien
d'origine je connais bien mon
arrière-grand-père était pécheur en rade
de Brest donc je pense que ce qu'on n'a
pas réussi jusqu'à présent mais qui va
falloir réussir parce que l'éluia
offshore aujourd'hui c'est 46 euros le
mégawattheure sur le dernier appel
d'offre même 44,9 €
y compris sur le site la fédération de
l'environnement durable aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui l'éolien offshore en Europe
c'est ce qu'il y a de moins cher et ça
va être le socle du mix énergétique
une fois qu'on a dit ça c'est aussi ce
que dit Agnès panière une pour les 10
prochaines années parce que le nouveau
nucléaire c'est bien après c'est qu'une
fois qu'on a dit ça comment fait-on pour
que cette
urgence de transition et de
réindustrialisation de la France ça va
être ultra décroissant on peut pas
s'opposer au développement rapide de
l'éolien offshore il y a peut-être des
ultra décroissants sur ce plateau mais à
partir de là
non justement donc à partir de là ce
qu'on n'a pas réussi jusqu'à présent
c'est de faire de du développement de
l'éolienne offshore qui a des marges
financières quand même y compris les
prix aujourd'hui il a des marches
financières de répartition de la
plus-value
d'en faire un élément du redéveloppement
de la pêche artisanale puisque la pêche
artisanale du Sud Bretagne aujourd'hui
de la Bretagne en général est en grande
difficulté il y a eu le brexit il y a un
plan de casse qui remet en cause
l'avenir de porc comme le guide Vinet
comme
les ports du pays bigoudeng qui sont les
principaux ports de pêche artisanales il
faut qu'une partie de la plus-value
aille sur ces territoires y compris
il faut dire quand même chose on
continue de pêcher dans les parcs et
pour ben si bien sûr que si comme ça
ça fait partie du contrat d'une comédie
locale
d'abord sur la durée de vie vous parliez
de la durée de vie de l'énergie
nucléaire centrale la durée de vie d'une
éolienne c'est 20 ans non à peu près
plus 25 ans on commence à détruire les
premières éoliennes non les détruits
pour les remplacer par des beaucoup plus
puissantes au même endroit peu importe
la technologie 95%
peuvent adapter réadapter président de
la commission de la pêche du Parlement
européen pendant 5 ans donc je connais
un peu le monde de la pêche je
revendique et les pêcheurs eux-mêmes et
très honnêtement aujourd'hui les
pêcheurs sont impactés directement par
l'installation des parcs éoliens c'est
évidemment puisque c'est sur leur zone
de pêche donc évidemment que ça impacte
leur activité leur activité économique
réadapter leur activité pourraient-ils
le faire soit parfois oui parfois non
c'est ce que je disais c'est pour ça que
je dis pas n'importe où pas n'importe
comment et pas n'importe quel prix
on met des éoliennes partout alors
faisons un point quand même projet
éolien justement on va regarder une
carte on va faire un point sur les
projets de parc éolien offshore et je
vous donne la parole Jean-Louis buffet
regardons cette carte ensemble il y a
celui de Saint-Nazaire on l'a dit déjà
en service pour les autres moi j'en ai
compté 16 10 posées 6 flottants certains
mises en service à l'horizon 2025
d'autres en 2027 d'autres en 2030 ou
encore en 2031 et des projets pilotes
également les contestations sont les
mêmes partout Jean-Louis dutret d'abord
il y a les parcs qui sont dans la zone
12 miles enfin de 12000 qui est mon avis
scandaleuse je pense à la baie de
Saint-Brieuc des choses comme ça c'est
le pire des endroits est-ce qu'on fait
de l'éolien offshore partout est-ce
qu'on est en train de mettre de
l'énergie
Dunkerque et jusqu'en 2000 si on prend
l'horizon 2030 il va y avoir 700
éoliennes qui vont être mis c'est ce que
vous disiez et alors c'est quoi c'est
quand même des usines électriques qu'on
met en mer alors moi je veux bien parler
de l'écologie mais quand on parle de
l'écologie l'écologie quoi c'est des
arbres c'est la nature c'est la mère
c'est le des fonds marins sains des
choses comme ça et d'un seul coup
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on sort on met du
béton on encre etc c'est de
l'industrialisation électrique et
parfois pas dans des endroits approprié
Cédric Philibert c'est vrai qu'il y a un
problème local ce qu'il faut quand même
d'abord voir c'est le au fond ça prend
assez peu de place en mer et en fait les
pêcheurs toutes les pêches sélectives
vont être vont pouvoir les pêcheurs
vous n'avez pas c'est entre deux
éoliennes il y a beaucoup de d'eau qui
d'autre
on ne peut pas travailler au chalut à la
drague on peut faire toutes les pêches
sélectives et l'avenir de la pêche toute
façon vous allez peut-être me contredire
là-dessus mais je crois qu'il est dans
la pêche sélective et de moins en moins
dans l'échalut si vous parlez des fonds
marins excusez-moi
c'est lié si vous parlez si vous parlez
de l'avenir de la pêche et il faut
parler de l'avenir de la pêche l'avenir
de la pêche ce qui est le plus menaçant
aujourd'hui pour la Maison de la Pêche
c'est la surpêche et c'est le labourage
des fonds marins donc il faut qu'on
aille vers des pêches plus sélectives
d'accord et ça va plutôt pas mal avec
avec les parcs éoliens qui de toute
façon n'occupe qu'une très faible partie
j'ai parlé
quelle est la différence sont-ils moins
invasifs moins moins alors oui bien sûr
parce qu'il y a consensus il n'y a qu'un
ancrage il n'y a qu'un ancrage au fond
et puis un câble pour beaucoup
d'éoliennes donc ils sont pas posés sur
le plancher de de mer
en général
une éolienne offshore
que ça pollue un peu moins mais écoutez
il faudrait quand même parler à des gens
qui connaissent j'ai un ami qui
s'appelle
l'association Robin des Bois vous devez
l'association des bois qui a fait plein
d'études ce sont des gens qui contestent
le fait en effet qu'actuellement on est
en train de détruire les fonds marins
bon il y a des plaintes actuellement qui
sont déposés et là j'entends des gens
qui disent un parc éolien c'est rien on
a un petit peu de béton écoutez
écologiste est-ce que ça détruits
tout simplement bon si tu es les sources
c'est-à-dire sinon on assène ah oui oui
oui 45 euros aujourd'hui prix moyen
l'éolien offshore en Europe
Eurostat
44,9 44,9 euros dernier parc un
Saint-Nazaire c'est trois fois moins que
le prix de le père vendu en Angleterre
ça c'est du factuel l'avenir énergétique
électrique européen
sur le factuel aussi environnemental
l'étude la plus poussée à notre
disposition c'est celle du Muséum
d'histoire naturelle de Belgique sur les
grands parcs offshore qui concluent la
mer du Nord
il n'y a pas d'impact significatif
l'époque adorent ça c'est mais ça c'est
les études des scientifiques parce que
vous pouvez assumer tout ce que vous
voulez pas de souci à chaque fois que
vous asseyez quelque chose vous me
mettez l'étude scientifique qui
correspond à ce que vous êtes en train
de dire moi tout ce que je dis il y a
une étude scientifique il y a des
données des instituts officiellement une
réponse à l'indicap rapport à l'exemple
que si tu es en Anglet les Fox sont en
surpopulation chers collègues va aller
voir aussi
j'ai pas dit ça aujourd'hui c'est pas un
argument de dire que les phoques
puissent se développer dans les parcs
et les pêcheurs peuvent pas les les
pêcher à cet endroit là très clairement
dire que donc pour la biodiversités
si je comprends bien il y a plusieurs
études qui disent des choses différentes
sur l'impact de l'éolien en mer non non
il y en a une fête par le Comité
national des pêches exemple des élevages
marins qui contestent évidemment qui
comptaient cette étude là et qui dit il
y a un impact réel sur la biodiversité
et sur sur la base de de l'éolienne qui
existe
parce que ce que cité Renan c'est sur la
base de d'éoliennes existant après il y
a des gens qui peuvent dire ça va faire
ça ou ça va faire ça mais comme il y a
très peu de parkings
d'accord française en fait en France sur
des parcs français il y a pas d'études
parce qu'il y a pas encore d'éolienne
vous pouvez tirer des conclusions parce
que il parle de Belgique
et on en saura plus dans les mois qui
viennent puisque Drakkar a été lancé ce
mois-ci c'est la première plateforme
française de recherche en mer dédiée à
l'éolien offshore et l'objectif est
effectivement d'étudier les effets des
parcs éolien en mer sur les oiseaux les
mammifères marins les poissons et les
récifs donc peut-être que nous aurons
une réponse plus précise dans les mois
qui viennent sur ce sujet on avance
pardonnez-moi l'éolien of Shore on le
voit ici et on le voit dans le film est
loin de faire l'unanimité parmi les
habitants parmi les élus et parmi les
citoyens selon certains tous ces débats
toute cette contestation cela fait
perdre beaucoup de temps à la France sur
la question de la transition écologique
et cela servirait les intérêts des
pollueurs écoutez
sans le vouloir ces gens là il retarde
la transition énergétique et ils font le
les beaux jours de pétroliers parce que
du coup on sera pas capable de passer en
chauffage en locomotion à travers
l'électricité et donc je crois que ces
gens là il voit pas l'impact de leur
action sur la faune et la fleur
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez répondre à
cela par exemple c'est toujours la même
réponse pardonnez-moi mais vaut mieux se
répéter que ce contredire c'est autour
de ce qu'on fait comme métier c'est
c'est pas n'importe où pas n'importe
comment et pas n'importe quel prix oui
il faut un mix énergétique je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord avec mon voisin de
droite oui il faut un mix énergétique
bien entendu il en faut mais encore une
fois pas n'importe comment et on voit
bien que moi je celui que je connais
mieux c'est celui de la médecin Brieuc
c'est un c'est une catastrophe
environnementale c'est c'est une
catastrophe à tout point de vue
également financière
contester du cadre du temps
je pense qu'il faut il faut débattre
maintenant il faut voir
tout le temps
je partage complètement il faut il faut
agir à un moment ou un autre c'est la
raison pour laquelle la France
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs tu citais madame
panière une hachée moi je le cite pas
très souvent mais je vais quand même la
citer et elle elle insiste sur le
développement le redéveloppement de
l'énergie nucléaire aujourd'hui en
France c'est très clair
c'est pas un autre débat c'est un débat
qui est lié directement au mix
énergétique il faut bien le dire
Jean-Louis on va avoir tous les
inconvénients c'est-à-dire que
l'Allemagne nettoie son nucléaire très
bien nous on développe notre nucléaire
on développe l'éolien en mer et alors en
plus on continue à accélérer l'éolien
terrestre c'est-à-dire qu'on a eu trois
inconvénients l'éolien le nucléaire peut
remplacer tout le reste je vous donne
juste un exemple les 700 éoliennes
en 2030 vont faire 10 gigawatts j'aime
pas citer les chiffres sur les plateaux
parce que les gens suivent pas en
général je m'excuse 10 gigawatts c'est
10 GW c'est quoi c'est de l'électricité
d'abord qui n'est pas fiable puisque ça
dépend du vent et ensuite ça correspond
exactement à un site comme si vous dans
la Vienne qui a deux réacteurs de 1750
MW non alors franchement pendant
jusqu'à 2030 on va complètement
électrifier toutes les côtes de France
pour voir ce que c'est c'est quand même
on est en train actuellement de rendre
malheureux des gens d'attaquer la pêche
parce que la pêche est morte avec ça
faut pas se tromper
oui on va la sauver mais n'empêche que
les attaquer
en plus à accélérer l'éolien terrestre
alors que on met de l'éolien en mer
c'est-à-dire
encore plus mauvais puisque l'éolien
offshore on peut estimer que le
rendement c'est à entre 35 et 40% une
éolienne bon 35 35%. l'éolien intéresse
c'est 23 ça veut dire que le reste une
éolienne ou l'ensemble de l'éolien
terrestre les trois quarts du temps il
sert à rien cette intervenant a dit
qu'on prenait du retard j'ai eu la
curiosité d'aller regarder où on en
était ailleurs dans le monde sur
l'éolien of Shore
simplement
en retard sur l'éolien en mer moi j'ai
regardé une liste en tout cas que j'ai
trouvé vous allez me dire si elle est
juste ou pas en terme de puissance
installée des parcs éoliens en mer voilà
le classement que j'ai trouvé la Chine
qui pulvérise des records d'éolien en
mer le Royaume-Uni notamment grâce à
l'Écosse en numéro 2 l'Allemagne en
numéro 3 les Pays-Bas le Danemark la
Belgique Taïwan le Vietnam et la France
9e juste avant la Suède est-ce qu'on est
temps à la traîne que ça Cédric Philippe
500 MW aujourd'hui alors que certains de
nos voisins ont dépassé les 10000
mégawatts on n'est pas vraiment en
avance on est dans le top 10 avec écoute
que nous avons et nous avons des
installations nous avons des
installations de production de
fabrication de tout des flotteurs pour
les éoliennes flottantes des des pylônes
des nacelles des pales etc on fait tout
en France mais c'est vrai que nous
n'avons pas un champion national de
l'éolien français industriel pourquoi
parce que on s'y est pris après tout le
monde et que ces champions sont danois
espagnol vous en citiez tout à l'heure
voilà et malheureusement il y en a pas
il y a pas de champions chez nous parce
qu'on s'y pris trop tard
mondiale
économie du monde avec la plus grande
l'éolien c'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga de
l'énergie donc non mais c'est important
un potentiel éolien offshore bien plus
grand que tout le reste du monde
cumulé mais que il y a aucune autre zone
qui a un potentiel pareil que l'Europe
notamment à cause de la Baltique et de
la mer du Nord qui sont qui sont avec
des hauts plateaux oui ça pose aucun
problème les fonds sont uniformes et
sont vaseux pour la plupart donc
évidemment c'est beaucoup plus facile de
la Bretagne
ça veut dire que c'est un très grand
potentiel d'énergie bon marché pour
l'Europe c'est un atout extraordinaire
et c'est pas normal que l'Europe ne soit
pas en tête de ce classement les échos
la semaine dernière se sont alertés de
de ce qui monte comme inquiétude des
grands industriels électro-intensifs
français c'est la marginalisation de la
France c'est-à-dire que on a sur la
table aujourd'hui du 40 euros
mégawattheure en éolien
du 20 25 euros en photovoltaïque et du
nucléaire à 120 euros
dans un monde libéral va acheter du 120
euros s'il a du vin 40 euros de
disponible
je m'excuse donc
faites un petit effort
les uns après les autres
journal libéral s'il en est et là il y a
une grande inquiétude Agnès panière une
haché dit le nucléaire
2035-2040 la nouvelle génération je suis
en désaccord avec elle sur ce point mais
elle est très très claire et moi je
participe à un des groupes de travail de
préparation de la loi énergie climat
pour dire et elle l'a dit au Sénat en
présentant la loi ENR si on n'a pas un
développement massif de l'éolien dans
les 6 7 prochaines années nous ne
passons pas nous ne passons pas alors si
on est vraiment très décroissant si on
ne veut pas réindustrialiser la France
on peut se poser à l'éolien ok mais si
on est responsable et rationnaire
compris pour les filières de la
transition
écologique énergétique sur la mobilité
on a peu de temps devant nous avant un
vrai problème et sur le taux de
disponibilité de l'éolien offshore on a
les cibles du parc de Saint-Nazaire qui
devait être à 42% actuellement puisque
là on a un parc qui fonctionne 42%
ce qui veut dire que Dave va gagner plus
d'argent que prévu parce que c'est quand
même EDF qui gagne pour moi c'est 35 %
est assez proche de la disponibilité du
vieux parc nucléaire français et là il y
a un rapport qui ont des comptes encore
qui est sorti quand on est à 60 € la
production du mégawattheure sur les
levier nucléaire donc il est déjà
beaucoup plus cher que l'éolien c'est ça
la réalité économique de la France on
parle de pourcentage de rendement c'est
important que les téléspectateurs le
comprennent ça veut dire que une
éolienne
elle ne peut pas fonctionner tout le
temps s'il y a trop de vent elle se met
en drapeau c'est à dire qu'elle se met
dans le sens du vent donc elle tourne
pas s'il y a pas assez de vent elle ne
tourne pas non plus donc il y a beaucoup
de périodes dans l'année où elle ne
produit pas d'électricité il faut quand
même le dire c'est et donc on a un
rendement alors moi j'y crois pas trop à
ton chiffre des termes si tu remets en
cause EDF en plus ça devient compliqué
est-ce qu'on a le choix entre 30 et 35 %
si tout va bien voilà nous rentrons dans
les détails techniques et nous parlons
nous nous parlons de l'acceptabilité du
part de des mois
je crois cette question de
l'acceptabilité mais la question c'est
aussi est-ce que nous avons le choix je
voudrais qu'on réécoute un extrait de
cette intervenantes sur Oui ou Non avant
nous le choix de passer aller au lit
Auchan la neutralité carbone à horizon
200050 elle ne se réalisera qu'avec un
développement massif
du nucléaire mais ça c'est pas l'objet
d'aujourd'hui et des énergies
renouvelables et quand on parle des
énergies renouvelables c'est toutes les
énergies renouvelables y compris les
oliens offshore et en exploitant
l'intégralité du potentiel que l'on a
sur l'ensemble de nos façades maritimes
c'est un incontournable
c'est donc un incontournable l'éolien
offshore Jean-Louis butret c'est un
c'est ce qu'on appelle le mix
énergétique et évidemment il faut qu'il
faut mettre un incont
ournable
et on en a pas besoin à partir du moment
le dans ce nucléaire nous n'avons pas
besoin de il y a un mensonge fondamental
qui a été dit dans cette affaire c'est
qu'on dit que ça va économiser du gaz à
effet de serre donc c'est bon pour le
climat alors je vous annonce un scoop
quand même c'est que toutes les études
qui ont été faites
montrent que c'est pas vrai ou c'est pas
prouvable
nous avons déposé une plainte devant la
Cour européenne de justice avec toutes
les études nécessaires et on n'est pas
les seuls il y a des ONG allemand il y a
des ONG belge c'est super ça nous aide à
perdre du temps encore plus oui je
l'espère bien
véritablement des crocodile
allez-y je pensais qu'un sénateur avait
quand même plus de recul on vous laisse
terminer et ensuite Cédric
philiberté
donc cette plainte européenne c'est pour
montrer que actuellement on a classé
l'éolien parce que c'est de l'argent
tout ça ça va profiter des fonds verts
ça va il faut voir les milliards qui
sont ponctionnés sur les factures
d'électricité partout etc pour alimenter
tout ça c'est subventionné et on a si on
redirige ça vers l'éolien et bien
écoutez il y a aucune preuve que ça soit
une industrie verte ça veut dire que la
Cour européenne de justice a accepté la
plainte deuxième scoop et qu'on a bien
l'intention de gagner parce que
justement là comme vous le dit qu'il
faut des sources il faut des experts et
il y a des experts qui travaillent dans
ce domaine il y a aucune preuve et tous
les fonds verts et j'arrête tous les
gens qui les banques qui sont en train
de diriger les fonds verts vers l'éolien
ils risquent d'avoir une surprise
importante alors parlons parlons
milliards depuis le 1er janvier 2022 ce
sont publics
en dessous c'est pas la peine
depuis le 1er janvier 2022 ce sont les
exploitants d'éoliennes qui versent à
l'état parce que le mécanisme du
complément de rémunération c'est
l'état paie jusqu'à un certain niveau
celui qui a été acté dans les dans les
enchères dans les contrats mais si le
prix de marché est plus élevé ce sont
les exploitants d'éoliennes qui payent
l'État au début ça devait être
simplement un remboursement maintenant
c'est à
limitum il y a pas de limite
la question
je m'inquiète pour eux en ce moment
parce que ce sera la conclusion de ce
débat l'éolien offshore est-il oui ou
non un incontournable il est absolument
nécessaire c'est ça sera 30% de notre
électricité et l'agriculture sera la
moitié plus de la moitié de notre
énergie donc c'est absolument
indispensable ça doit rester un
complément ça doit rester un complément
c'est indispensable mais c'est un
complément notre production énergétique
par rapport au nucléaire notamment il
nous manque il nous manque dans les 10
prochaines années plusieurs centaines de
terrate Water pour passer c'est agnèse
qui le dit ce sont les études de RTE ce
sont les études de l'État donc
effectivement il faut laisser
me sentais conclure
je crois que il y a un débat qui se
termine c'est qu'effectivement c'est le
moins cher et c'est absolument
nécessaire le débat là-dessus se termine
et tous les groupes de travail de la loi
énergie climat dont on discutera à
l'automne on se cadre là après je pense
que mais là on n'aura pas le temps d'en
parler de manière un peu plus
raisonnable et cadré sur la plus-value
effectivement est-ce que la plus-value
va au soutien à la pêche artisanale qui
a besoin de financement pour se
réorganiser et qui fait de très belles
choses moi je connais bien les pêcheurs
de guerre qui préservent mais absolument
les pêcheurs dediens la pêche artisanale
de bière est absolument exemplaire et la
ressource
dans la loi ENR ça c'est un abonnement
que j'ai déposé qui a été gardé
l'Assemblée nationale un peu contre les
républicains mais il est passé quand
même au Sénat avec des centristes c'est
que une petite part du de la du gain
pour les exploitants de parc éolien
terrestres va aller sur la biodiversité
et notamment sur les programmes
nationaux d'espèces puis par exemple le
plus fin des Baléares et sensibles aux
éoliens offshore mais on n'aura pas le
temps de discuter de l'avenir depuis fin
des Baléares qui est simplement je
confirme ce que je disais tout à l'heure
l'éolien doit rester un complément et
encore une fois on ne voit pas le faire
n'importe où n'importe comment et c'est
ce qu'on fait en ce moment en France
voilà ce que je regrette et ce sera le
mot de la fin merci merci infiniment à
tous les quatre d'avoir accepté de
débattre plus ou moins sereinement merci
en tout cas de nous avoir suivi comme
chaque semaine à très vite sur Public
Sénat merci
[Musique]